farewell office this is probably the
last time we'll step foot in here
[Music]
good morning everybody well it's not
actually morning anymore it's 11
25 technically it is a morning so good
morning everybody and uh today is an
exciting
day because i just brought back a new
car
i did not buy a new car but i rented a
new car off a turo so
game plan for me right now is to try it
and buy a new car and i've been driving
a volkswagen jet for a long time
everyone around me has got new cars
constantly and i want a new car
so i've been in the market for an suv
plan ahead for
a bigger family and whatnot and the key
atelier ride has caught my attention for
it
looks for its luxury for its relatively
low price for all that luxury
and for its abilities to go off-roading
i don't know
that's kind of like how they market this
car i've always been having an affinity
for off-roading although i've never part
took any off-roading myself because i
never had any vehicles to go off-roading
something i've always wanted to get into
and uh if you really want to go
off-roading the tell your ride's
probably not the car to buy
but hey i'm trying to balance out
everything you know a family car a
little bit of luxury a little bit of
that a little bit of off-roading a
little bit of this the kia tele rides
where i landed on
in order to test drive it for longer
than five minutes because when you go to
the dealership they only want you to
drive around the block and if you ask to
drive more they're kind of like
oh yeah you're in the mileage
value so sure i get it they're trying to
sell that car
so instead of test driving off the lot
i've decided to use the turo app
to rent a car to rent the exact car i
want so for the next two days i have a
key italia ride good morning mi familia
buenos dias
morning isaac said i look like a tourist
so i'm like what's up
somehow that's true you're just missing
a camera or something or
having a phone or a selfie stick or
something and you look like
a kid that just rolled out of bed you
look like a high school kid now
with the high school college get up with
the
the hoodie messed up hair the the dude
boys
the rounded shoulders the hunchback oh
let's go i can't wait till we actually
have this
car in our family casey's been super
excited about it i've been super excited
for him because
like i don't know ever since i got the
tesla i'm like dude just
get the thing you want and be happy
because i know what that feels like and
i want you to have that feeling
and so all this time we've been um
thinking about getting it so then now
that we rented it
for a whole weekend i'm really excited
to check it out
wait i gotta get my shoes oh where's
your shoes in here
all right drumroll please oh
snap
[Music]
how did you enjoy uh driving it over
here i loved it put in sportsman
this thing is like kind of new
kind of did the guy tell you when he got
it uh yeah like
two months ago oh yeah so you bought it
this looks like about two months long
oh this is exactly the one that we want
to get to with the captain chairs
captain chairs the double sunroof
oh yeah cool
can you open it we need to do that first
oh
there we go yes
that's dope i love that oh that's cool
it's huge yeah
like does it open open or just i don't i
think it's just that noise
yeah and then i could like barely
is that all of it that's all of it only
when we're parked
yeah dang it looks very spacious yeah
it's gonna be perfect so tomorrow we're
gonna be doing a halloween drive-through
type of thing where
i've got tickets for us to go so it's
like one ticket per
car so that's the reason why we rented
out this car because we wanted to be
able to take aunt and christina with us
and obviously the babies so we're
clearing out the jk
downtown office so that's another reason
why i needed a car to
move some bigger pieces of furniture
this is like the ultimate test drive
the ultimate test drive of just driving
the car with the three at the core
family here
and then extended family and friends and
car seats test which is going to be with
aunt and christina
and then moving big bulky items which is
going to be later today we're doing all
that
all of it so that's like the this is the
ultimate test drive look what i found
out
what'd you find out oh nice
it's better than the back seat of my car
we could go back to that one camping
spot we went this is our camping vehicle
now
the reason why we haven't bought it and
the reason why it's taking so long
is because of the fact that we want
white interior
and they're not taking custom orders in
california and so we were looking into
possibly ordering it in texas and we
could double it as a road trip to go
visit his family
but why haven't we made moves huh this
is all his department
so i've been i've been scouring around
and it seems like it's a seller's market
a seller's market meaning that
dealership has all the negotiating
powder power
negotiating powder is good you need to
sprinkle on some of yourself and you can
negotiate a lot better but i don't have
that powder right now
so uh so yes i will be paying a lot more
and i
i talked to the guy that rented this car
to me he said that uh he paid
12 000 more above msrp price ooh
so it's like that's that's a lot that's
like that's uh
you're paying for it a luxury car at
that point you're paying yeah bmw
according to jess if you pay msrp you're
a sucker so you're still a sucker yeah
that guy really he did not get a good
deal yeah he he was he's me
and if i wasn't as
controlled as i am right now reading
everything he was just like i needed
this card and
he just bought it so he's baller
man it's hard for me to talk with these
invisalign thingies and
yeah yeah it's like you're you're you're
in character you're you're the tourist
character
oh yeah i can't even hear your wish no
no i can hear your dear boys i can't
even hear your lips
i remember around that point like when
my voice started changing i liked
modulating my voice because i
had a range now i'm like oh i could go
really low for one
two and talk like this into here
what did you just find out if we go to a
road trip right we could buy like a a
little
screen we could play the switch oh yeah
that's your little little tv right here
a little tv tv set up right here
like we can put it right here true they
do have those
holder thingies for like an ipad
how cool imagine once we have a car seat
in there
with the white seats oh white seats and
car seats hmm
i don't know that's a good mix i like
the black to be yeah
yeah you know what as as time progresses
i'm also letting go of the
the the light interior i'm just like i
kind of just want the top trim
whatever color it comes in i'm sure and
then the faster the better right
yeah yeah i don't know maybe we'll just
head down
sometime soon what the whoa
oh yeah it's not your car oh yeah is
this down here
tesla's over here you're just like the
classic movie trope and someone's trying
to
drive something and then the wipers turn
on instead whoa the steering wheel is
like
really like scary pretty cool it's
pretty
cool hey you look hot you look like a
soccer mom now it's different from your
car for sure
which is nice yeah i like this uh
interior of the car big fan of this
what do you think isaac i like it yeah i
like it so far yeah
yes i got isaac's approval sometimes i
like to do this and hold on for dear
life
oh nice i get the comfort it comes from
comfort it's comforting it's comforting
yeah he doesn't like it that my tesla
doesn't have the handles
so when i was shopping for a car another
big factor was
trying to find a car that was cool
enough for isaac when i was a teenager i
remember thinking like
that is really cool yes there's no way
you can hit anything now
i'm like this is like old technology
that a lot of cars have now but i'm like
so new to this because i'm like
my career doesn't have 360 cam when i
was shopping yeah i was i was
considering what isaac would want to
because look there's front cameras too
i'm like so blown away yeah i was always
considering what isaac would want
because he spends
just as much time as we do in these cars
and so i i consider everyone at least
the core family like the comfort level
the amenities and all these things and
if you can supply it why not
why not try to attain it right the
selling points for me
for an isaac's case was having the back
to have their own personal uh usb
charging port because i consider your
next few years is going to be you're
going to be having a
phone ipad switch whatever whatever
you're going to need i bet it here while
it's charging i can just watch some
youtube
true very very true that's nice
blanket that's that's luxury right there
luxury
this car pretty much hits everything
that i was looking for you know a little
bit of ruggedness a little bit of luxury
family car i know it sounds like a brand
new
sock it's not a brand deal not a brand
new you know ikea
we're in the market i was laughing
because it literally took me like 10
million times to like get into even with
the cameras
oh it's kind of it's pretty tight
squeeze it's a tight squeeze yeah
nice this guy set everything up i know
android oh no wait usbc you know usb
c is coming to iphone 12. so now
androids and
iphones are gonna have the same the two
universes are colliding
all right we are now at the office took
this beauty for a ride
and uh gotta pick up some furniture we
haven't been here in a long time
actually so it's uh
kind of weird to be back at this office
so ever since the pandemic
we've worked solely out of the monterey
park office
so i haven't come to this downtown
office oh that's scary
and not much has changed uh in fact it
actually seems kind of empty out here
seems like a lot of people closed up
shop
how does it feel to be back been like
over a year since i set foot here but
i don't feel like i really missed it a
lot of our fellow
tenants here did not survive isaac was
saying
it feels weird to be back yeah i miss
that guy
whoa it's so different
oh yeah what the hell happened here uh
oh scott mark what's the
not a scuff mark that's scratch fake
plants more fake plants let's put it on
the
backyard true for the ac unit oh
we could our old thingies trolls
oh my goodness isaac remember this room
yeah
this is the room when uh you came
me and mommy were working and we
couldn't uh take you home and we just
had to spend long hours at the office
you would sleep right here and you're
like
seven years old you'd play xbox and just
kind of chill here
[Music]
really did you ever use it no not really
a toilet oh yeah it's probably out of
battery too
oh for sure it is totally trees i was
ready to spend the night out here oh
back when i reached the film jiggy party
and
it was across the way over there and
we'd be like drenched with gunk or
whatever it was the challenge that we
did
i had my toiletry bag too and my own
towel even my hair towel
and like a whole thing here oh we forgot
about this
oh yeah that's always cool i like that
we have a spot for it keep it in your
side
of the bedroom because you always have
things on the floor yes that'd be
perfect
yeah did you ever use this yeah did you
ever use it
no not really i like that chair sitting
in too yeah
you know what i really like the way we
decked out this office
oh these china balls too oh look at the
waterproof mattress thingy for the futon
because then isaac would fall asleep on
a futon he'd be drooling on it
did you pee before no no you're too old
for that
oh the division flash cards
oh here's the old xbox oh yeah that's
360.
oh dang 360. yeah i gave one away
murphy where'd he get stained not my
fault i don't know oh it's probably when
the dogs were coming here and vomit and
stuff
oh yeah and it's so plain to do like the
one guys delivers the dogs but somehow
they always ended up in your office
whoa this is crazy looking farewell
office this is probably the last time
we'll step foot in here
maybe we can ask them we can keep those
for our backyard oh those are cool
yeah yeah just got so excited
how much for all of these we could put
it all up against the wall
and then now we don't have to worry oh
sure we don't have to build anything oh
i'm so excited
yeah we just have to weigh it down these
are pretty weighted huh text them now
text them now
get this we're going to bring this home
with us so we can put it in our backyard
you still remember how to ride that
thing
michael said please take it i'm so
excited
you know you know why he said please
take it why because he's like
i hate selling stuff on opera but i'm
like i feel you too i hate selling
someone offer up
so excited it is not and it's not fun
selling stuff especially during spend
time
oh i'm so excited our becker is going to
look nice
i asked him about the hoverboard he said
take it he thought it was actually
broken
we should have came back to the office
way sooner yeah
show the vlog how you used to ride it so
isaac found an ingenious way to ride it
and you were like
really really good at this i'm gonna get
a new one
you want to get a new we just this is a
new one
[Music]
oh my gosh i'm so excited we're taking
everything no matter how successful you
are in life or which you get and
i would never turn down free 99 no never
i love it
dang still got the skills yeah the
u-turn nice
i remember recording me doing this i
think in an old vlog yeah
[Music]
you want to be scary if i go too fast a
little shut down
my knees will go ow your face plant
oh that was scary
[Music]
it looks so cool and looks so funny at
the same time
cool we got some work to do let's do it
all hands on deck all right we have
moved
all the plants over there we've moved uh
i don't know if here's some stuff
uh mainly my my office is cleared out
now we saw the before
and this is the efta yep so this is
gonna be uh how many trips are we doing
oh i also found these hard drives and
uh one of the desks that were gonna be
sold
is labeled jk films four terabyte and
works these are the hard drives that we
use to uh
put all our footage that we shot for all
the jk skits the hard drives that
had all the current projects being used
i guess being edited and all that stuff
so these were working hard drives
and i have no idea what's on here and
it's fire a firewire so this is
some old school technology i wouldn't
want this to be sold
accidentally when that other desk is
being sold so
glad i was rummaging through all the
drawers and stuff so yes
save some hard drives
no thank you if i look like at least a
five then
keep it yes you look like a ten
oh my gee is this my christmas tree
probably we don't have a christmas tree
i got it to jk many years ago
okay it's pointless having a christmas
tree with our darn
cat they'll just yeah and they just
shred it tread it up i'm actually
thinking about getting an inflatable
tree
this year you know where we have the
pumpkins outside
i think that's just where we're gonna
have our inflatable tree because we
don't have any room inside the house
true all right so we have already gone
well actually well it's first off it's
11 o'clock now
been almost like seven hours of work we
did take a dinner break
yeah yep brain is dead yeah i'm tired
my arms are really sore because
yesterday and christina came over
and leia and enzo are with us and so i
was holding them a lot
and so my arms are already sore from
like carrying babies
yeah you had the mom workout yesterday
oh my god my arms are sore
this should be hopefully the last trip i
think so hopefully
i kind of want to take that bamboo too
that's joe's oh true
we gotta ask him first but yeah so we
pretty much moved everything
that was here we had so much stuff here
all gone
it's at our house now in our garage and
we have two more of the or four more of
these uh
trees coffee table and that's it
so that pillow is a set of four pillows
those are memories by the way those
pillows came with my
old couch that i bought by myself back
in 2010
and i bought my very first couch along
with that fridge that
we recently got rid of and yeah so i
bought pillow covers
so i'm keeping the covers throwing away
the pillows but there's one missing so
i'm like where did my
my other pillow go i kind of said those
pillows are going to the
dumpster because uh those are the first
pillows i got
i cuddled up next to you ah old school
cast
oh yeah i wonder what's gonna happen
with that these people
and dogs and pets are no longer with us
yeah
all right wait the pets are in heaven
but the people
are still on earth that's honest
good times purple hair yeah
purple hair you yeah did i change much
i'm over here
i know you're right there i didn't
change much and here's my
still holding a camera isaac changed
this little name yeah that's isaac
oh yeah isaac was a was a
dramalian soldier
yeah i wonder what what's gonna happen
to all this stuff we gotta move it to
the monarch park office
there's no room i know i remember when
we first moved in
it i always felt like this place was
really cold and like dungeness and like
like drafty i just felt like weird
first time we saw this it was just one
gigantic
room and it was all white oh warehouse
yeah it was just like
endless possibilities but then once
they got they hired the interior
designer for
this space for some reason she decided
to go with
dungeon yeah she went dark with
everything and no one likes
ever coming here because it just felt
depressing yeah
that's when they tried sprucing it up
with the yellow yellow
and then like the beach photo thing in
the back yeah
it was tainted yeah we've already
developed the behavior of not wanting to
be here
yeah yeah this office did not get used
as much as it was intended to be
yeah at least not by the jkb barbell you
still barbell uses it yeah
using it it just goes to show that
bigger is not better and that monitor
park office that we always use
is there's something about it that just
feels more like home even though it's
really dirty and you don't keep up with
it it just feels like home
and uh until you said it was really
charming yeah it's just been
that has been home for the past decade
already yeah
it's kind of like i don't know we tried
we tried
we never got there yeah they even added
this to try to make it
lively like the forest yeah
also the parking was not great parking
sucks here
we're in downtown l.a so the traffic was
horrible so even just to get to the
location was like
not desirable at all true
bye peace
gonna miss you
tada the last of the plants and the
coffee table
done dessert we got luckily we were able
to move all this stuff and not get
one single scratch on this car i know
skills
one is
[Music]
you